well it was a weekend in the united
states so of course we had another one
of these unspeakable tragedies involving
guns and this one is particularly bad we
always have mass shootings in the u.s
it's hard to find a weekend without at
least one mass shooting but we had a
particularly bad one and this one
because of the rhetoric involved because
of the alleged manifesto left behind by
the
alleged killer
we actually have insight into the
stochastic terrorism element of this
situation so i'm going to explain it to
you
as a reminder tragically i've been
talking about stochastic terrorism on
this program for at least 11 years back
in 2011 i did a segment called
stochastic terrorism and violent
rhetoric
unpredictability of shooters and the
fundamental idea
is that given a large enough audience if
you pump out a particular message time
and time and time again focusing anger
and focusing resentment and antipathy
towards a particular group of
individuals
you will at a certain point
uh influence someone enough who says i'm
going to go and shoot bomb whatever the
case may be we've had instances of this
in the past and here we have one related
to so-called great replacement theory or
white replacement theory
and
critical race theory and all of it so
let's take it step by step
mass shooting took place over the
weekend at tops friendly market
supermarket in buffalo new york 10
people were killed three were injured of
the 13 victims 11 were black and two
were white and this was not a
coincidence this was not by mere chance
this is uh being considered a hate crime
the shooter live streamed part of the
attack on twitch twitch says they caught
it within two minutes and cut the stream
the shooter uh
is white
18 year old and deliberately traveled to
an area with a higher population of
black people because he wanted to kill
black people the shooter was wearing
body armor and a military-grade helmet
and armed with three firearms a
semi-automatic rifle a legisl allegedly
a bushmaster xm15
a hunting rifle and a shotgun that's
what we know right now and had a head
mounted camera that's the camera from
which the event was streamed
the suspect was captured alive and was
arraigned in the buffalo city court
on the day of the shooting represented
by a public defender felony hearings
scheduled to begin later this week in
front of a grand jury he's being held
without bail
now this is where it starts to get you
know oh don't make it political well
right-wing political media
literally wrote the script for this
guy's manifesto
he reportedly wrote the shooter an uh
180 page manifesto that was released
prior to the shooting i'm i'm not going
to publish the manifesto but you can
find it i'll give you some of the
highlights and there's actually a good
twitter thread by j.j mcnabb a fellow at
george washington university's program
on extremism
some of the things from the manifesto
the shooter self identifies as a white
supremacist fascist with neo-nazi
beliefs who is anti-high fertility
immigrants under the white replacement
theory
this is the idea that uh immigrants who
aren't white come to the u.s to have a
lot of kids to demographically take over
the country
he states he was radicalized online on
4chan and was inspired by brenton
terrance manifesto and live streamed
mass shooting in new zealand you might
remember that one the shooter chose his
target because it has a higher
percentage of black americans than other
nearby areas
the manifesto is 180 pages long dozens
of pages are nothing more than
anti-black and anti-semitic memes and
statistics and almost 100 pages
contained mind-numbingly boring info
about every piece of equipment he
considered taking on the shooting spree
now there is so much to talk about here
there's the mentally ill thing
right the this what oftentimes you know
we've seen this before and and i don't
do this but you often see the trend of
if the shooter is muslim then it's
radical beliefs that are responsible and
the community of the individual
if it's a young white dude
then it's a lone mentally ill guy whose
mental illness alone and not the fact
that the manifesto reads like a fox news
script are responsible
it's important to remember a couple of
things one
in some sense you can argue
any of these people are not mentally
right anybody willing to do this is not
mentally right
but when you look at the manifesto
it's perfectly cogent and coherent and
it's not someone who doesn't understand
the consequences of their actions and
most importantly most mentally ill
people are not violent most mentally ill
people never commit a violent act look
at the list of so-called mental
illnesses now i know that not all of
these are exactly the same category but
think about you know anxiety bipolar
disorder depression ocd paranoia
paranoid schizophrenia delusional
disorder borderline personality disorder
mania panic disorder ptsd
depersonalization derealization disorder
anorexia bulimia parasomnias kleptomania
this is a broad range of stuff
but the point is almost none of the
folks with those conditions ever become
violent now i get that something is
wrong with the people who are violent
but to say oh well this is just a
mentally
just a therapist solves this problem
ignoring the political motivations
ignoring the access to firearms ignoring
all of it
when you look at the manifesto it's
articulate fascist fascist
racist hate
linked to ideas that we see in corporate
media the talk about white birth rates
the document talks about critical race
theory that's something i mean listen
that
it's like a republican talking point at
this point in time it says that it's all
part of a jewish plot
and oftentimes there's anti-semitism in
this stuff it's the full complement of
the things they've been pushing openly
since trump became president even since
right before when his campaign started
now let's just look at some examples
here's ben shapiro democrats want open
borders they want to bring in tens of
millions of illegals to vote the biden
administration has done less than
nothing they're not talking about ending
title 42 which would basically allow the
borders to be swamped their own dhs is
estimating up to 18 000 people a day may
be descending on the border which of
course completely destroys whatever
semblance of order there is on the
border there isn't much there right now
so what do you make of the border
situation it's i think it's literally
criminal what biden and the
administration has done you know they
swore to faithfully defend and uphold
the laws of the united states and and
remember almost nothing different is
being done by biden versus trump at the
border it's not even like they're trying
it's not like they're trying and failing
right that would be bad enough mirror
incompetence would be costly enough but
they just want this open border this is
their policy program from the democrats
perspective they like it it's good uh
it's 225 000 people coming across every
month not every year every month the
amount of fentanyl that comes over every
month is enough to kill every american
twice over of course most of the people
uh brought over trafficked by cartels so
there's a human slavery component you
know the women and children are horribly
abused bonafide humanitarian crisis and
it's just bad it's bad for everybody in
arizona it's bad for the whole country
uh but this is the way democrats like it
and again i'm bold enough to to admit
the obvious right which is that they're
doing this so that someday they can
amnesty these people and make them
voters who they expect to vote democrat
this is an electoral strategy for the
democrats their policies are so bad and
so so we've already debunked this
extensively even if it was what
democrats wanted to do it's a terrible
terrible strategy
strategy and i've explained many times
why the math of it doesn't make any
sense but the point is here is that
anger at democrats deliberately dumping
in tens of millions of illegals into the
country that's not what democrats want
to do tucker carlson remember immigrants
make our country poorer and dirtier good
evening and welcome to tucker carlson
tonight here's a funny thing that we
noticed the other day people debate all
the time about mass immigration
what you never hear anybody do is make
the economic case for mass immigration
but as an economic matter this is insane
it's indefensible so nobody even tries
to defend it instead our leaders demand
that you shut up and accept this we have
a moral obligation to admit the world's
poor they tell us even if it makes our
own country poorer and dirtier and more
divided there i mean it's it's hard to
get more specific rhetoric than that
that is straight out of the manifesto
here's another tucker carlson clip where
he is doing the replacement theory
talking points that were echoed in the
shooter's manifesto
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown absolute contempt
for our customs our laws our system
itself and they're being treated better
than american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest the
democratic party is trying to replace
the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world but they
become hysterical because that's that's
what's happening actually let's just say
it that's true
if look if this was happening in your
house if you were in sixth grade for
example and without telling i remember
covering this at the time listen to this
your kid your parents adopted a bunch of
new siblings and gave them brand new
bikes and let them stay up later and
help them with their homework and gave
them twice the allowance that they gave
you
you would say to your siblings you know
i think we're being replaced by by kids
that our parents love more
and it becomes
this is the great replacement theory
stuff that was in the manifesto uh
charlie kirk has been pushing this stuff
president joe biden's department of
defense will accept 30 000 afghan
refugees in the military installations
following the collapse of kabul
boom
political
transformation there it is
let the country crumble do you know
there's five million displaced people in
afghanistan now
this was all intentional
joe biden let it fall apart to now say
oh i'm so sorry i guarantee you joe
biden's speech this afternoon we'll talk
about refugee assistance and relocation
support yep the entire point of getting
out of afghanistan was so it would go
poorly so that then they can bring in
people to replace white people from
afghanistan lauren bobert has done this
stuff yes there is um definitely a
replacement theory that's going on right
now we are killing american jobs and
bringing in illegal aliens from all over
the world world to replace them if
americans will not comply replace them
replace them so
there is serious responsibility here i'm
not saying there's going to be
accountability i'm not saying what
they're doing is criminal the term
stochastic terrorism is not a criminal
term it's a term that we as reasonable
people can say wow they repeat this
rhetoric and then the rhetoric is used
in a manifesto and it's what made this
guy go and seek out black people
i'm not saying you can charge any of
them i'm just saying we have to speak
honestly and acknowledge that these
ideas didn't come out of thin air now
one other note before we move on this
was not the only mass shooting this
weekend so yes there was the mass
shooting in buffalo but we also had a
mass shooting in milwaukee with 17
injuries on friday and we also had mass
shootings in houston texas laguna woods
california amarillo texas
as well as winston-salem north carolina
this weekend so always remember in the
united states of america there's never
just one mass shooting and we do
ultimately get to
the question of what do we do because
there's this fallacy of tolerance if we
tolerate the intolerant
then they go out
and kill people and they those people
that die no longer can practice that
tolerance there there is this uh uh
fallacy there and this problem that
needs to be dealt with and we're going
to keep covering all of this but we of
course we have to talk about what fox
news is blaming as well